demonstrators outside the French Embassy
the police were there not to stop them
but to protect them there are supporters
of President Paul Biya he's been in
power since 1982 they're angry at the
French president a man ran amok home
he's been openly critical of the
government security crackdown on the
english-speaking regions of Cameroon
where armed separatists are seeking
autonomy supporters of the government
hold signs saying no one can divide
Cameroon and don't mess with our
country's affairs who is this young 40
year old who's trying to teach a lesson
to our old presidents as this protester
look what they've done to Libya Ivory
Coast in Mali they're not going to mess
with us they then all insult the French
president it's this mobile phone video
widely shared on social media that
sparked the protest the person filming
is a Cameroonian political refugee in
France he shouts to Macomb to get his
attention he says more than 29 people
were burned to death last week in the
english-speaking regions by security
forces
everyone is flee what are you going to
do he asks I am putting maximum pressure
on Paul Biya so that he deals with the
crisis in the Anglophone regions and
that he treats the political opposition
with respect and eventually freed
opposition leader Maurice counter we are
seeing that the situation is
deteriorating and I will call him so
that the intolerable situation ceases
with a billion displaced and over 3,000
killed since 2016 human rights groups
blame both armed separatists and
security forces for the violence and
displacement of people in the
english-speaking regions
Human Rights Watch believes the Rapid
Intervention battalion backed by ethnic
Fulani militias are behind the latest
attack the elite force trained and
managed by former Israeli Navy commandos
shot 13 children then set their homes
alight for the parents and children
inside
the government first called it
collateral damage then denied being
involved the killings were so outrageous
and the abuse is so blatant and the
evidence so damning the killings were
deliberate and were aimed at punishing
the population suspected of harboring
and collaborating with the separatists
the opposition believes these
demonstration against France are
orchestrated by the government itself
while France may be cameroon's closest
ally the relationship is changing the
violence in the english-speaking regions
is intensifying improving too brutal to
ignore Nicolas honk al-jazeera